effet de serre réchauffement climatique
courants marins des notions pas toujours
évidente à expliquer aux plus jeunes à
guyancourt un forum de la météo et du
climat était proposée au public le 21
janvier
un moyen ludique d'aborder des
thématiques importantes
les intervenants avec lesquels on
travaille s'appelle ils sont issus de
l'association les savants fous
donc ça fait quelques années qu'on
travaille avec eux etc des animateurs
scientifiques qui sont formés pour
intervenir auprès du public du jeune
public
c'est un outil de sensibilisation c'est
de l'information et sous la direction du
professeur bidibulle les curieux
deviennent apprentis savant alors ils
ont commencé une petite expérience pour
comprendre que la biomasse dégage du co2
dans l'atmosphère avec des levures du
sud de l'eau chaude et en dégageant co2
a fait gonfler un ballon non ils sont en
train de faire des tornades
donc on voit un petit peu comment
fonctionne le phénomène de la tornade
entre l'eau douce mais
le 2 mai dans le duel était plus légère
et aussi bad bad avec du co2 on pouvait
faire gonfler un ballon on a fait des
expériences avec une bouteille ou y
avait de l'eau dedans et du colorant et
ensuite on a retourné la bouteille on
avait vu que ça faisait internet
j'ai appris de nouvelles choses et cela
vient plus les 60 enfants inscrits aux
ateliers ont pu repartir avec leur
expérience pour les réaliser en famille
en partenariat avec le secteur
développement durable et météo france ce
forum aura réuni plus d'une centaine de
personnes